[Applause]
summer in florence
tuesday idea between mri machine at the
dommel trump junior at the weald earth
day morning something about my senpai
number
europe known by dismay criticism
e-com in your table
diablo business within the timber sector
allectura peshmerga beyond the presence
who face  so times soul and i grow up
after all my back and forth between
president donald trump will know me
by the the other women at the label
coloring hobby
joy sony and the double jersey grant
kimberly
so object orange immensely fathers are
there john mccain
to the notes  on ice t is the president at
hdc bar him in the house
okay fine other thing do you have fantasy
growerapp
de put the one you're all businessman
and when all vergis condolences to the
daytime host for the lessons for dad
aan de more recently korea joyfully  just
any less right side of
jetfire no what are you thinking oh my god
in gold back to mingle de just how she
felt de at the president stream and or
other  s
specifically hear yes how peaceful and also track
obama in the 2000 presidential
election
and aj pinky pin code this time for my
data and step simon from single bundle
wash with warm and the pin fitting an
ensemble boom we never take anything
to my game which the white  house
righteous one nl
is there is it was a bit the pen
of the have a warm vermeersch and
psilocine his father is and your father
would connect chips in new york city in your neck on
this peaches and cream for scavenger
paper modules wallet jungle why
the country  and as ivory for effects by
the policy for getting to their american
dream i in that we a kim brailey or
former fox news host
grinding and die emotional and now your
father for a person way in project
my heart terms that family better
arjan de votes and  arno wooden pots
i my rather type colleagues start with
a free psn taken je family of the ball
hard with yes and jazz hands reynders
dmr have maisbult my acquaintances c  atcher
this gave
highlighter die be more stability when
will i did what would be die and the
diffuse de the situation to ride my final
and then I have my tone new
fashion player the audience anp note in
pouch black frame to duo
timings the staff and you  can do joy
and memories with a jump for joy titi
cameras rolling
at the open delbar get the president
house oil helps after a tire despite
their jeffer politics oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
in my driver sanity check this
particular moment  hi-macs already because god there
but is the show with such trigger is for
the left and right and people go crazy
for all the lists nanking
new hearts that one team the counter you
stay on
[Music]